The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: OK, we have
a busy day today,
so let's get started.
Want to go through Chernoff
bounds and the Wald identity,
which are closely related, as
you'll see, and that involves
coming back to the TG1Q a little
bit and making use of
what we did for that.
It also means coming
back to hypothesis
testing and using that.
Would probably have been better
to start out with
Wald's identity and the Chernoff
bound and then do the
applications when it was at
the natural time for them.
But anyway, this is the way it
is this time, and next time
we'll probably do
it differently.
Suppose you have a random
variable z.
It has a moment generating
function.
Remember, not all random
variables have moment
generating functions.
It's a pretty strong
restriction.
You need a variance.
You need moments
of all orders.
You need all sorts of things,
s but we'll assume it exists
in some region between
r and r plus.
There's always a question,
with moment generating
functions, if they exist up
to some maximum value of r
because some of them exist at
that value of r and then
disappear immediately after
that, and others just sort of
peter away as r approaches
r plus from below.
I think in the homework this
week, you have an example of
both of those.
I mean, it's a very
simple issue.
If you have an exponential
distribution, then as r
approaches, the rate of that
exponential distribution,
obviously, the moment generating
function blows up
because you're taking e to the
minus lambda x, and you're
multiplying it by a the r x.
And when r is equal to lambda,
bingo, you're integrating 1
over an infinite range, so
you've got infinity.
If you multiply that exponential
by something which
makes the integral finite when
you set r equal to lambda,
then of course, you have
something which
is finite at r star.
That is a big pain
in the neck.
It's usually not important.
The notes deal with it very
carefully, so we're not going
to deal with it here.
We will just assume here that
we're talking about r less
than r plus and not worry about
that special case, which
usually is not all
that important.
But sometimes you have
to worry about it.
OK, the Chernoff bound says
that the probability that
random variable is greater than
or equal to alpha is less
than or equal to the moment
generating function evaluated
at some arbitrary value r times
e to the minus r alpha.
And if you put it in terms of
the semi invariant moment
generating function, the log
of the moment generating
function, then the bound
is e to the gamma z of
r minus alpha r.
When you see something like
that, you ought to look at it
and say, gee, that looks funny
because here, we're taking an
arbitrary random variable and
saying the tails of it have to
go down exponentially.
That's exactly what this says.
It says that a z takes
on very large values.
This is a fixed quantity here
for a given value of r, and
it's going down as e to the
minus r times alpha.
As you make alpha larger and
larger, this goes down faster
and faster.
So what's going on?
How do you take an arbitrary
random variable and say the
tails of it is exponentially
decreasing?
That's why you have to insist
that the moment generating
function exists because when the
moment generating function
exists for some r, it means
that the tail of that
distribution is, in fact, going
down at least that fast,
so you get something
that exists.
So the question is what's the
best bound of this sort of
when you optimize o for r?
Then the next thing we did is
we said that z is a sum of
IID, then the semi invariant
moment generating function for
that sum is equal to n times
the semi invariant moment
generating function for the
underlying random variable x.
S of n is n of these IID
random variable.
So one thing you see
immediately, and ought to be
second nature to you now, is
that if a random variable has
a moment generating function
over some range, the sum of a
bunch of those IID random
variables also has a moment
generating function over
that same range.
You can just count on that
because the semi invariant
moment generating function
is just n times this b.
OK, so then what we've said is
the probability that sn is
greater than or equal to na,
where na is playing the role
of alpha and sn is playing the
role of z, is just a minimum
over r of e to the n times gamma
x of r minus ra, and the
n is multiplying the ra
as well as the n.
OK, this is exponential
n for a fixed a.
In other words, what you do in
this minimization, if you
don't worry about the special
cases or anything, how do you
minimize something?
Well, obviously, you want to
minimize the exponent here, so
you take the derivative of this
gamma prime of r has to
be equal to a.
Then n can be whatever it wants
to be when you find that
optimum r, which is where gamma
prime of r equals a,
then this goes down
exponentially with a.
Now, however, we're interested
in something else.
We're interested in threshold
crossings.
We're not interested in picking
a particular value of
a and asking, as n gets very,
very big, what's the
probability that the sum of
random variable is greater
than or equal to n times a.
That is exponential in n, but
what we're interested in is
the probability that s of n is
greater than or equal to just
some constant alpha, and what
we're doing, now, is instead
of varying n and varying
this with n also,
we're holding the stick.
So we're asking as n gets very,
very large, but you hold
this alpha fixed, what happens
on this bound over here?
Well, when you minimize this,
taking the same simple-minded
view, now the n is not
multiplied by the ra.
It's just multiplied
by the gamma x.
You get n times gamma prime of
r is equal to alpha s where
the minimum is so that it says
gamma prime of r is optimized
when you pick gamma prime of r
equal to alpha over and n.
This quantity is minimized when
you pick gamma prime of r
equal to alpha over n.
So if you look at this bound as
n changes, what's happening
is, as n changes, r is changing
also, so this is a
harder thing to deal with
for variable n.
But graphically, it's quite
easy to deal with.
I'm not sure you all got the
graphical argument last time
when we went through it, so I
want to go through it again.
Let's look at this exponent r
minus n over alpha times gamma
of r, and see what
it looks like.
We'll take r, pick
any old r, there.
What we want to do is show that
this, if you take a slope
of alpha over n, and take an
arbitrary r, come down to
gamma of x of r, draw a line
in this slope, and look at
where it hits the horizontal
axis here, that point is r
plus the length of
this line here.
The length of this line here
is gamma of r, that's a
negative value, times 1 over
that slope of this line.
And 1 over the slope of this
line is n over alpha, so when
I pick a particular value of r,
the value of the experiment
I have is this value here.
How do I optimize this over r?
How do I get the largest
exponent here?
Well, I think of varying r, as
I vary r from 0, and each
time, I take this straight
line here.
And I start here, draw a
straight line over there,
start here, draw a straight
line over, start at this
tangent here, draw a
straight line over.
And what happens when I come
to larger values of r?
Just because gamma of s of r is
convex, what happens is I
start taking these slope lines,
slope alpha over n, and
they intercept the horizontal
axis at a smaller value.
So this is optimized over r
at the value of r0, which
satisfies alpha over n equals
gamma prime of r0.
That's the same answer we got
before when we just used
elementary calculus.
Here, we're using a more
sophisticated argument, which
you learned about probably
in 10th grade.
I would argue that you learned
mostly really sophisticated
things when you're in high
school, and then when you get
to study engineering in college,
somehow you always
study these mundane things.
But anyway, aside from
that, why is this
geometric argument better?
Well, when you look at these
special cases of what happens
when gamma of r comes around
like this, and then suddenly
it stops in midair and just
doesn't exist anymore?
So it comes around here, it's
still convex, but then
suddenly it goes off
to infinity.
How do you do that optimization
then?
Well, the graphical argument
makes it clear how you do it,
and makes it perfectly rigorous
how to do it, whereas
if you're doing it by calculus,
you've got a really
think it through, and it
becomes fairly tricky.
OK, so anyway, now, the next
question we want to ask--
I mean, at this point, we've
seen how to minimize this
quantity over r, so we know what
this exponent is for a
particular value of n.
Now, what happens
when we vary n?
As you vary n, the thing that
happens is we have this
tangent line here, a
slope alpha over n.
When you start making n larger,
alpha over n becomes
smaller, so the slope
becomes smaller.
And as n approaches infinity,
you wind up going way,
way the heck out.
As n gets smaller, you
come in again.
You keep coming in until you
get to this point here.
And what happens then?
We're talking about
a line of--
maybe I ought to draw
it on the board.
It would be clearer, I think.
As n gets smaller, you
get a point which is
tangent here, this here.
When you're here, the tangent
gets right here, so we've
moved all the way into this
quantity we call r star, which
is the root of the equation
gamma of r equals 0.
Gamma of r equals 0 typically
has two roots, one
here, and one at 0.
It always has a root at 0
because moment generating
function evaluated is 0 is
always 1, so the log of
it is always 0.
There should be another root
because this is convex, unless
it drops off suddenly, and even
if it drops off suddenly,
you can visualize it
as a straight line
going off to infinity.
So when you get down to this
point, what happens?
Well, we just keep
moving along.
So as n increases, we start
out very large.
We come in.
We hit this point, and then
we start coming out again.
I mean, if you think about it,
that makes perfect sense
because what we're doing here is
we're imagining experiment
where this random variable has
a negative expected value.
That's what's indicated by
this quantity there.
We're asking what's the
probability that the sum of a
large number of IID random
variables with a negative
expected value ever rises above
some positive threshold?
Well, the law of large numbers
says it's not going to do that
when n is very, very large,
and this says that, too.
It says the probability of
it for n very large is
extraordinarily small.
It's e to the minus 10 times
an exponent, which is very,
very large.
So as n gets very small, it's
not going to happen either
because it doesn't have time
to get to the threshold.
So there's some intermediate
value at which it's most
likely to cross the threshold,
if you're going to cross the
threshold, and that intermediate
value is just
that value at which gamma of
r star is equal to zero.
So the probability this union
of terms, namely the
probability you ever cross
alpha, is going to be, in some
sense, approximately a to the
minus alpha r star because
that's where the dominant
term is.
The dominant term is where
alpha over n is
equal to gamma prime.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
where'd I put that?
r star satisfies gamma
of r star equals 0.
When you look at the line of
slope, gamma prime of r plus
of r star, that's where you get
this critical value of n
where it's most likely the
cross the threshold.
OK, I put that somewhere.
I thought it was on this slide,
but it's the n, the
critical n, let's call it n
crit, is equal to gamma prime.
Is at right?
Alpha over m is the
gamma prime.
Alpha over n, 1 over n crit.
n crit, this says, is alpha over
gamma prime of r star.
OK, so that sort of nails down
everything you want to know
about the Chernoff bound accept
for the fact that it is
exponentially tight.
The text proves that.
I'm not going to go
through that here.
Exponentially tight means, if
you take an exponent which is
just a little bit larger than
the one you found here, and
look what happens as alpha
gets very, very
large, then you lose.
OK, let's go on, and at this
point, we're ready to talk
about Wald's identity.
And we'll prove Wald's identity
at the end of the
lecture today.
Turns out there's a very,
very simple proof of it.
There's hardly anything to it,
but it seems more important to
use it in several ways first so
that you get a sense that
it, in fact, is sort
of important.
OK, so we want to think about
a random walk, s sub n and
greater than or equal to n, so
it's a sequence of sums of
random variable, s sub
n is equal to x1
plus up to x sub n.
The x's are all IID.
This is the thing we've been
talking about all term.
We have a bunch of IID
random variables.
We look at the partial
sums of them.
We're interested in what happens
to that sequence of
partial sums.
The question we're asking here
is does that sequence of
partial sums ever cross
a positive threshold?
And now we're asking does
it ever cross a positive
threshold, or does it cross a
negative threshold, and which
does it cross first?
So the probability that it
crosses this threshold is the
probability that it
goes up, first.
The probability that it crosses
this threshold is the
probability that it
goes down, first.
Now, what Wald's identity says
is the following thing.
We're going to assume that
x is not identically 0.
If x is identically
0, then it's never
going to go any place.
We're going to assume that it
has a semi invariant moment
generating function in some
region, r minus to r plus.
That's the same as assuming
that it has a generating
function in that region, so it
exists from some value less
than zero to some value
greater than zero.
And we picked two thresholds,
one of them positive, one of
them negative, and we let j be
the smallest value of n. j is
a random variable, now, because
we've start to run
this random walk.
We run it until it crosses one
of these thresholds, and if it
crosses the positive threshold,
j is the time at
which it crosses the
positive threshold.
If it crosses the negative
threshold, j is the time that
it crosses the negative
threshold.
We're only looking at the first
threshold that it crosses.
Now, notice that j is
a stopping trial.
In other words, what that means
is you can determine
whether you've crossed a
threshold at time n solely in
terms of s1 up to s sub n.
If you see all these sums, then
you know that you haven't
crossed a threshold
up until time n.
You know you have crossed
it at time n.
Doesn't make any difference
what happens at times
greater than n.
OK, so it's a stopping trial
in the same sense as the
stopping trials we talked
about before.
You get the sense that Wald's
identity, which we're talking
about here, is sort of like
Wald's equality, which we
talked about before.
Both of them have to do with
these stopping trials.
Both of them have everything
to do with stopping trials.
Wald was a famous statistician,
not all that
much before your era.
He didn't die too long ago.
I forget when, but he was one
of the good statisticians.
See, he was a statistician who
recognized that you wanted to
look at lots of different
models to understand the
problem, rather than a
statistician who only wanted
to take data and think that he
wasn't assuming anything.
So Wald was a good guy.
And what his identity says is,
and the trouble with his
identity, is you look at
it, and you blink.
The expected value of
e to the r s sub j.
s sub j is the value of the
random walk at the time when
you cross a threshold minus
the time at which you've
crossed a threshold
times gamma of r.
So when you take the expected
value of e to the this, you're
averaging over j over the time
that you crossed the
threshold, and also at the value
at which you crossed the
threshold, so you're averaging
over both of these things.
And Wald says this expectation
not is less than or equal to
1, but it's exactly 1, and it's
exactly 1 for every r
between r minus and r plus.
So it's a very surprising
result.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
please explain
why j cannot be defective?
I don't really see it.
PROFESSOR: Oh, it's because
we were looking at two
thresholds.
If we only had one threshold,
then it could be defective.
Since we're looking at two
thresholds, you keep adding
random variables in, and the
sum starts to have a larger
and larger variance.
Now, even with a large variance,
you're not sure that
you crossed a threshold,
but you see why you
must cross a threshold.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If the MGF is defined
at r minus, r plus,
then is that also [INAUDIBLE]
quality?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Oh, if it's defined at r plus.
I don't know.
I don't remember, and I would
have to think about it hard.
Funny things happen right at the
ends of where these moment
generating functions are
defined, and you'll see why
when we prove it.
I can give you a clue as to how
we're going to prove it.
What we're going to do is, for
this random variable x, we're
going to define another random
variable which has the same
distribution as x except
it's tilted.
For large values of x, you
multiply it by e to the rx.
For small values of
x, you multiply it
by e to the rx also.
But if r is positive, that
means the positive values
could shifted up, and the small
values get shifted down.
So you're taking some of the
density that looks like this,
and when you shift it to this
tilted value, you're shifting
the whole thing upward.
When r is negative,
you're shifting
the whole thing downward.
Now, what this says is that
tilted random variable, when
it crosses the threshold, the
time of crossing the threshold
is still a random variable.
You will see that this simply
says that the expected value
of that tilted random variable
is equal to--
it says that tilted random
variable is, in fact, the
random variable.
It's not defective.
And it's the same argument as
before, that has a finite
variance, and therefore, since
it has a finite variance, it
keeps expanding.
It will cross one of the
thresholds eventually.
OK, so the other thing you can
do here is to say, suppose
instead of crossing a threshold,
you just fix this
stopping rule to say we'll
stop at time 100.
If you stop at time 100, then
what this says is expected
value of e to the r100 minus
100 times gamma of
r is equal to 1.
But that's obvious because the
expected value of e to the r
is j is, in fact--
it's j times the expected value
of rx, so then you're
subtracting off j times
the log of the
expected value of rx.
So it's a trivial identity
if x is fixed.
OK, so Wald's identity
says this.
Let's see what it means in terms
of crossing a threshold.
We'll assume both thresholds
are there.
Incidentally, Wald's identity
is valid in a much broader
range of circumstances than
just where you have two
thresholds, and you're looking
at a threshold crossing.
It's just that's a particularly
valuable form of
the Wald identity.
So that's the only thing
we're going to use.
But now, if we assume further
that this random variable x
has a negative expectation,
when x has a negative
expectation, gamma of r
starts off going down.
Usually, it comes
back up again.
We're going to assume that this
quantity r star here,
where it crosses 0 again, we're
going to assume there is
some value of r, for which
gamma of r star equals 0.
Mainly, we're going to assume
this typical case in which it
comes back up and crosses
the 0 point.
And in that case, what it says
is the probability that sj is
greater than or equal to alpha
is just less than or equal to
e to the minus r star
times alpha.
Very, very simple bound
at this point.
You look at this, and you sort
of see why we're looking, now,
not at r in general,
but just r star.
At r star, gamma of r
star is equal to 0.
So this term goes away, so we're
only talking about the
expected value of e to the r
sj, e to the r star sj is
equal to 1.
So let's see what happens.
We know that e to the r star sj
is greater than or equal to
0 for all values of sj because
e to the anything real is
going to be positive.
OK, since e to the r star sj is
greater than or equal to 0,
what we can do is break this
expected value here, this term
is 0, now, remember, break
it into two terms.
Break it into the term where s
sub j is bigger than alpha,
and break it into the
term where s sub j
is less than beta.
So I'm just going to ignore the
case where it's less than
or equal to beta.
I'm going to take this
expected value.
I'm going to write it as the
probability that s sub j is
greater than or equal to alpha
times e times the expected
value of either the r star s
sub j given s sub j greater
than or equal to alpha.
There should be another term
in here to make this equal,
and that's the probability that
s sub j is less than or
equal to beta times e to the r
star s sub j, given that s sub
j is less than or
equal to beta.
We're going to ignore that, and
that's why we get the less
than or equal to 1 here.
Now, you can lower bound
e to the r star
sj under this condition.
What's a lower bound to s sub
j given that s sub j is
greater than or equal
to alpha?
Alpha.
OK, we're looking at all cases
where s sub j is greater than
or equal to alpha, and we're
going to stop this experiment
at the point where it
first exceeds alpha.
So we're going to lower bound
the point where it first
exceeds alpha by alpha itself,
so this quantity is lower
bounded, again, by taking the
probability that s sub j
greater than or equal to alpha
times e to the r star alpha,
and that whole thing is less
than or equal to 1.
That says the probability that
sj is greater than or equal to
alpha is less than or equal to
e to the minus r star alpha,
which is what this inequality
says here.
OK, so this is not
rocket science.
This is a fairly simple result
if you believe in Wald's
identity, which we'll
prove later.
OK, so it's valid
for all choices
of this lower threshold.
And remember, this probability
here, it doesn't look like
it's a function of both alpha
and beta, but it is because
you're asking what's the
probability that you cross the
threshold alpha before you
cross the threshold beta.
And if you make beta very, very
large, it makes it more
likely that you're going
to cross the threshold.
If you make beta very close to
0, then you're probably going
to cross beta first, so this
inequality here, this quantity
here, depends on beta also.
But we know that this inequality
is valid no matter
what beta is, so we can let beta
approach minus infinity,
and we can still have
this inequality.
There's a little bit tricky
math involved in that.
There's an exercise in the text
which goes through that
slightly tricky math, but what
you find is that this bound is
valid with only one threshold,
as well as with two
thresholds.
But this proof here that we've
given depends on a lower
threshold, which is somewhere.
We don't care where.
Valid for all choices of
beta, so it's valid
without a lower threshold.
The probability that the union
overall n of sn less than or
equal to alpha.
In other words, the probability
that we ever
crossed a threshold alpha--
AUDIENCE: It's not true equal.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: It's supposed to
be sn larger [INAUDIBLE]
as the last time?
PROFESSOR: It's less than or
equal to e to the minus r star
alpha, which is--
AUDIENCE: Oh, sn?
sn?
PROFESSOR: n.
AUDIENCE: You just [INAUDIBLE]
[? the quantity? ?]
PROFESSOR: Oh, it's a union
overall n greater than or
equal to 1.
OK, in other words, this
quantity we're dealing with
here is the probability
that sn---
oh, I see what you're saying.
This quantity here
should be greater
than or equal to alpha.
You're right.
Sorry about that.
I think it's right
most places.
Yes, it's right.
We have it right here.
The probability of this union
is really the same as the
probability that the value of
it, after it crosses the
threshold, is greater than
or equal to alpha.
OK, now, we saw before that the
probability that s sub n
is greater than or
equal to alpha.
Excuse me, that's the same.
When you're writing things in
LaTeX, the symbol for less
than or equal to is so similar
to that for greater than or
equal to that's hard to
keep them straight.
That quantity there is a greater
than or equal to sign,
if you're going from right to
left instead of right to left.
So all we're doing here is
simply using this, well,
greater than or equal to.
OK, the corollary makes a
stronger and cleaner statement
that the probability that you
ever cross alpha is less than
or equal to--
my heavens, my evil twin got
a hold of these slides.
And let me rewrite that one.
The probability that the union
overall n of the event s sub n
greater than or equal to alpha
is less than or equal to e to
the minus r star alpha.
OK, so we've seen from the
Chernoff bound that for every
n this bound has satisfied, this
says that it's not only
satisfied for each n, but it
says it's satisfied overall n
collectively.
Otherwise, if we were using the
Chernoff bound, what would
we have to do to get a handle
on this quantity?
We'd have to use the union
bound, and then when we use
the union bound, we can show
that for every n, the
probability that sn is greater
than or equal to alpha is less
than or equal to
this quantity.
But then we'd have to add all
those terms, and we would have
to somehow diddle around with
them to show that there are
only a few of them which are
close to this value, and all
the rest are negligible.
And the number that are close to
that value is only growing
with n and goes through
a lot of headache.
Here, we don't have to do this
anymore because the Wald
identity has saved is from
all that difficulty.
OK, we talked about
the G/G/1 queue.
We're going to apply this
corollary to the G/G/1 queue
to the queueing time, namely to
the time w sub i that the
i's arrival spends in
the queue before
starting to be served.
You remember, when we looked at
that, we found that if we
define u sub i to be equal to
the ith interarrival time
minus the i minus first service
time, those are
independent of each other,
so this is the
difference between those.
So ui is the difference between
the i's arrival time
and the previous service time.
What we showed was that this
sequence, u sub i, the
sequence of the sums of u sub
i as a modification of a
random walk.
In other words, the sums of
the u sub i behave exactly
like a random walk does, but
every time it gets down to 0,
if it crosses 0, it
resets to 0 again.
So it keeps bouncing up again.
If you look in the text, what
it shows is that if you look
at this sequence of u sub i's,
and you look at the sum of
them, and you look at them
backward, if you look at the
sum of u sub i plus u sub i
minus 1 plus u sub i minus 2,
and so forth, when you look at
the sum that way, it actually
becomes a random walk.
Therefore, we can apply this
bound to the random walk, and
what we find is that the
probability that the waiting
time of n queue, of the nth
customer, is probability that
it's greater than or equal to
an arbitrary number alpha is
less than or equal to the
probability that w sub
infinity is greater than or
equal to alpha, and it's less
than e to the minus
r star alpha.
So again, all you have to do is
you have this inner arrival
time x, you have this service
time y, you take the
difference of the two, that's a
random variable, you find a
moment generating function of
that random variable, you find
the point of r star at which
that moment generating
function equals 1, and then
the bound says that the
probability that the queueing
time that you're going to be
dealing with is less than
or equal to this
quantity alpha here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What do you work with
when you have the gamma
function go like this, and thus
have infinity, and you
cross it there.
[INAUDIBLE] points that
we're looking for?
PROFESSOR: For that, you
have to read the text.
I mean, effectively, you can
think of it just as if gamma
of r is a convex function
like anything else.
It just has a discontinuity in
it, and bingo, it shoots off
to infinity.
So when you take these slope
arguments, what happens is
that for all slopes beyond that
point, they just seesaw
around at one point.
But the same bound holds.
OK, so that's the
Kingman bound.
Then we talked about
large deviations
for hypothesis test.
Well, actually we just talked
about hypothesis test, but not
large deviation for them.
Let's review where
we were on that.
Let's let the vector y be an n
tuple of IID random variables,
y1 up to y sub n.
They're IID conditional
on hypothesis 0.
They're also IID conditional on
hypothesis 1, so the game
is nature chooses either
hypothesis 0 or hypothesis 1.
You take n samples of some IID
random variable, and those n
samples are IID conditional on
either nature choosing 0 or
nature choosing 1.
At the end of choosing those n
samples, you're supposed to
guess whether h0 is the right
hypothesis or 1 is a right
hypothesis.
Invest in Apple stock 10 years
ago, and one hypothesis is
it's going to go broke.
The other hypothesis is it's
going to invent marvelous
things, and your stock will
go up by a factor of 50.
You take some samples, you make
your decision on that.
Fortunately, with that, you can
make a separate decision
each year, but that's the
kind of thing that
we're talking about.
We're just restricting it to
this case where you have n
sample values that you're taking
one after the other,
and they're all IID when the
particular value of the
hypothesis that happens
to be there.
OK, so we said there
is something called
a likelihood ratio.
The likelihood ratio for a
particular sequence y is
lambda of y is equal to the
density of y given h1 divided
by the density of y given h0.
Why is it h1 on the top
and h0 on the bottom?
Purely convention,
nothing else.
The only thing that
distinguishes hypothesis 1
from hypothesis 0 is you choose
one and call it 1, and
you choose the other
and call it 0.
Doesn't make any difference
how you do it.
So after we make that choice,
the likelihood
ratio is that ratio.
Now, the reason for using semi
invariant moment generating
functions is that this
density here is
a product of densities.
This density is a product of
densities, and therefore when
you take the log of this ratio
of products, you get the sum
from i equals 1 to n of this log
likelihood ratio for just
a single experiment.
It's a single experiment that
you're taking based on the
fact that all n experiments
are based on the same
hypothesis, either h0 or h1.
So the game that you're playing,
and please remember
what the game is if you forget
everything else about this
game, is the hypothesis gets
chosen, and at the same time,
you take n sample values.
All n sample values correspond
to the same value of the
hypothesis.
OK, so when you do that, we're
going to call z sub i, this
logarithm here, this log
likelihood ratio.
And then we showed last time
that a threshold test is--
well, we define the threshold
test as comparing the sum with
the logarithm of a threshold.
And the threshold is equal to
p0 over p sub 1, if in fact
you're doing a maximum a
posteriori probability test,
and p0 and p1 are the
probabilities of hypothesis.
Remember how we did that.
It was a very simple thing.
You just write out what the
probability is of hypothesis 0
and a sequence of
n values of y.
You write out what the
probability is of hypotheses 1
and that same sequence of values
with the appropriate
probability on that sequence for
h equals 1 and h equals 0.
And what you get out of that
is that the threshold test
sums up all the z sub i's,
compares it with the
threshold, and makes a choice,
and that is the map choice.
OK, so conditional on h0, you're
going to make an error
if the sum of the z sub i's
is greater than the
logarithm of eta.
And conditional on h1, you're
going to make an error if the
sum is less than or
equal to log eta.
I denote these as the random
variable z sub i 0 to make
sure that you recognize that
this random variable here is
conditional on h0 in this case,
and it's conditional on
h1 in the opposite case.
OK, so the exponential bound
for z sub i sub 0--
OK, so what we're doing now is
we're saying, OK, suppose that
0 is the actual value
of this hypothesis.
0 is the value of
the hypothesis.
The experimenter doesn't
know this.
What the experimenter does is
does what the experimenter has
been told to do, namely the
experimenter take these n
values, y1 up to y sub n, finds
the likelihood ratio,
compares that likelihood ratio
with the threshold, and if the
threshold is larger than the
threshold, it decides 1.
If it's smaller than the
threshold, that decides
opposite thing.
It decides 1 if it's above
the threshold, 0 if
it's below the threshold.
Well, first thing we want to do,
then, is to find the log
likelihood ratio under the
assumption that 0 is the
correct hypothesis, and
something very remarkable
happens here.
Gamma sub 0 of r is now the
logarithm because it's a semi
invariant moment generating
function of the expected value
of this quantity of e to
the r times z sub i.
When we take the expected value,
we integrate over f of
y given h0 times e to the r
times log of f of y given h1
over f of y given h0.
You look at this, and
what do you get?
This quantity here is e
to the r times log of
f of y given h1.
That whole quantity in there
is just f of y given
h1 to the rth power.
So what we have is, in this
quantity here, is f of y given
h0 to the minus r power.
So this term combined with
this term gives us f of 1
minus r of y given h0, and this
quantity here is f to the
r of y given h1 dy.
So the semi invariant moment
generating function is this
quantity here.
At r equals 1, this is just f
of y given h1, so the log of
it is equal to 0.
So what we're saying is that,
for any old detection problem
in the world, so long as this
moment generating function
exists, what happens is it
starts at 0, it comes down,
comes back up again, and
r star is equal to 1.
That's what we've just shown.
When r is equal to 1, this whole
thing is equal to 1, so
the log of 1 is equal to 0.
For every one of these problems,
you know where this
intercept is, you know where
this intercept is, one is at
0, one is at 1.
What we're going to do now is
try to find out what the
probability of error is given
that h is 0, h equals 0, is
the correct hypothesis.
So we're assuming that the
probabilities are actually f
of y given h0.
We calculate this quantity that
looks like this, and we
ask what is the probability
that this sum of random
variables exceeds the threshold,
exceeds the
threshold eta.
So the thing that we do is we
draw a line, a slope, natural
log of eta divided by eta.
We draw that slope along here,
and we find that the
probability of error is upper
bounded by gamma 0 of this
quantity, defined by the slope,
minus r0 times log of
eta divided by eta.
That's all there is to it.
Any questions about that?
Seem obvious?
Seem strange?
OK, so the probability of r
conditional on h equals 0 is e
to the n times gamma 0 of
r0 minus r0, natural
log of eta over eta.
And ql of eta is the probability
of error given
that h is equal to l.
OK, we can do the same thing
for hypothesis 1.
We're asking what's the
probability of error given
that h equals 1 is the correct
hypothesis, and given that we
choose a threshold, say
we know the a priori
probabilities, so we choose
a threshold that way.
OK, we go through the same
argument, z1 of s is the
natural log of f of y given F1
times e to the s, we're using
s in place of r here, times
the natural log of f of y
given h1 over f of y given h0.
And this quantity, now, f of y
given h1, the f of y given h1
is upstairs, so we have f of
1 plus s of y given h1.
This quantity is down here,
so we have f of minus
s of y given h0.
And we notice that when s is
equal to minus 1, this is
again equal to 0, and we notice
also, if you compare
this, gamma 1 of s is equal
to gamma 0 of r minus 1.
These two functions are the
same, just shifts it by one.
OK, so this one of the very
strange things about
hypothesis testing, namely you
are calculating these expected
values, but you're calculating
the expected value of a
likelihood ratio.
And the likelihood ratio
involves the probabilities of
the hypotheses also, so when you
calculate that ratio, what
you get this is funny quantity
here, which is related to what
you get when you calculate
the semi invariant moment
generating function given
the other hypothesis.
So that now, what we wind up
with is a gamma 1 of the eta,
is e to the n times
gamma 0 of r0.
I'm using the fact that gamma 1
of s is equal to gamma 0 of
r minus 1, s is just r shifted
over by 1, so I can do the
same optimization for each.
So what I wind up with is
the probability of error
conditional on hypothesis 0,
is this quantity down here.
That's this one, and the
probability of error
conditional on the other
hypothesis, the exponent is
equal to this quantity here.
OK, so what that says is that
as you shift the threshold--
in other words, suppose instead
of using a map test,
you say, well, I want the
probability of error to be
small when hypothesis
0 correct.
I want it to be small when
hypothesis 1 is correct.
I have a trade off between
those two.
How do I choose my threshold in
order to get the smallest
value overall?
So you say, well,
you're stuck.
You have one exponent
under hypothesis 0.
You have another exponent
under hypothesis 1.
You have this curve here.
You can take whatever value you
want over here, and that
sticks you with a value here.
You can rock things around this
inverted seesaw, and you
can make one probability of
error bigger by making the
other one smaller, or you make
the other one bigger by making
the other one smaller.
Namely, what you're doing is
changing the threshold, and as
you change the threshold, as
you make the threshold
positive, what you're doing is
making it harder to accept h1,
h equals 1, and easier
to accept h equals 0.
When you move the threshold the
other way, you're making
it easier the other way.
This, in fact, gives you the
choice between the two.
You decide you're going
to take n tests.
You can make both of these
smaller by making n bigger.
But there's a trade off between
the two, and the trade
off is given by this tangent
line to this curve here.
And you're always stuck with
r star equals 1 and
all of these problems.
So the only question is what
does this curve look like?
Notice that the expected value
of the likelihood ratio given
h equals 0 is negative.
The expected value given h
equals 1 is positive, and
that's just because of the form
of the likelihood ratio.
OK, so this actually shows
these two exponents.
These are the exponents for
the two kinds of errors.
You can view this as a large
deviation form of the Neyman
Pearson test.
In the Neyman Pearson test,
you're doing things in a very
detailed way, and you're
taking a choice between
choosing different thresholds
to make the probability of
error of one type bigger or less
than the other one, just
the other way.
Here, we're looking at the large
deviation form of it
that becomes an upper bound
rather than an exact
calculation, but it tells you
much, much more because for
most of these threshold tests,
you're going to do enough
experiments that your
probability of error is going
to be very small.
So the only question is where
do you really want the error
probability to be small?
You can make it very small one
way by shifting the curve this
way, and make it very small the
other way by shifting the
curve the other way.
And you take your choice
of which you want.
OK, the a priori probabilities
are usually not the essential
characteristic when you're
dealing with this large
deviation kind of result
because, when you take a large
number of tests, this threshold,
log eta over eta
over n, when n becomes very
large, when you have a large
number of experiments,
log eta over n
becomes relatively small.
So that's not the thing you're
usually concerned with.
What you're concerned with is
whether one test, the patient
dies, and the other tests costs
a lot of money; or one
test, the nuclear plant blows
up, and the other test, you
waste a lot of money,
which you wouldn't
have had to pay otherwise.
OK, now, here's the important
part of all of this.
So far, it looked like there
wasn't any way to get out of
this trade off between choosing
a threshold to make
the error probability small one
way, or making the error
probability small
the other way.
And you think, well,
yes, there is a way
to get around it.
What I should do is what I do
in real life, namely if I'm
trying to decide about
something, what I'm normally
going to do, I don't like to
waste my time deciding about
it, so as soon as the decision
becomes relatively
straightforward, I
make up my mind.
If the decision is not
straightforward, if I don't
have enough evidence, I keep
doing more tests, so
sequential tests are an obvious
thing to try to do if
you can do it.
What we have here, what we've
shown, is we have two coupled
random walks.
Given hypothesis h equals 0, we
have one random walk, and
that random walk is typically
going to go down.
Given h equals 1, we have
another random walk.
That random walk is typically
going to go up.
And one is going to go down, one
is going to go up, because
we've defined the random
variable involved is a log of
f of y given h1 divided by f
of y given h0, which is why
the 1 walk goes up, and
the 0 walk goes down.
Now, the thing we're going to
do is do a sequential test.
We're going to keep
doing experiments
until we cross a threshold.
We're going to decide what
threshold is going to give us
a small enough probability of
error under each condition,
and then we choose
that threshold.
And we continue to test
until we get there.
So we want to find out whether
we've gained anything by that,
how much we've gained
if we gain something
by it, and so forth.
OK, when you use two thresholds,
alpha's going to
be bigger than 0.
Beta's going to be
less than 0.
The expected value of z given
h0 is less than 0, but the
value of z given h1
is greater than 0.
That's why the walks are
coupled, so we can handle each
of them separately until we can
get the answers for one
from the answers
for the other.
Crossing alpha is a rare event
for the random walk with h0
because a random walk
with h0, you're
going to go down typically.
You hardly ever go up.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you please
explain again sign of
expectations?
PROFESSOR: The sign of
the expectations?
Yes, z is the log, so that when
we actually have h equals
1, the expected value of this
is going to be lined up with
this term on top.
We have f of y.
When we have h equals 0,
this lined up with
the term on the bottom.
I mean, actually, you have to
go through and actually show
that the integral of f of y
given h1 of this quantity is
greater than 0, and the other
one is less than 0.
We don't really have to do that
because, if we calculate
this moment generating
function, we can
pick it off of there.
When we look at this moment
generating function, that
slope there is the expected
value of z conditional on h
equals 0, and because of the
shifting property, this slope
here is the expected value of
z given h equals 1, just
because the 1 curve is shifted
from the other by one unit.
It's really because
of that ratio.
If you defined it the other
way, you just changed the
sign, so nothing important
would happen.
OK, so r start equals 1 for
the h0 walk, so the
probability of error, given h0,
is less than or equal to e
to the minus alpha.
Well, that's a nice simple
result, isn't it?
In fact, that's really
beautifully.
You just calculate this moment
generating function, you find
the root of it, and
you're done.
You have a nice bound, and in
fact, it's an exponentially
tight bound.
And on the other hand, when you
deal with the probability
of error given h1 by symmetry,
it's less than or equal to e
to the beta.
Beta is a negative number,
remember, so this is
exponentially going
down as you choose
beta, smaller and smaller.
So the thing that we're getting
is we can make each of
these error probabilities as
small as we want, this one, by
making alpha big.
We can make this one as
small as we want by
making beta big negative.
There must be a cost to this.
OK, but what's the cost?
What happens when you
make alpha big?
When hypothesis 1 is the correct
hypothesis, what
normally happens is that this
random walk is going to go up
roughly at a slope of the
expected value of z
given h equals 0.
So when you make alpha very,
very large, you're forced to
make a very large number of
tests when h is equal to 1.
When you make beta very, very
large, you're forced to take a
large number of tests when
h is equal to 0.
So the trade off here is
a little bit funny.
You make your error probability
for h equals 0
very, very small by costing more
money when hypotheses 1
is the correct hypothesis
because you don't make a
decision until you've
really climb way up
on this random walk.
And that means it takes a long
time when you have h equals 1.
Since when h is equal to 1, the
probability of crossing
this lower threshold is it is
almost negligible, this
expected time that it takes
is really just a
function of h equals 1.
I'm going to show that
in the next slide.
When you increase alpha, it
lowers the probability of
error given h equals 0.
Excuse me, I should have h
equals 0 instead of h sub 0.
Exponentially, it increases the
expected number of steps
until you make a decision
given h1.
Expected value of j given h1 is
effectively equal to alpha
divided by expected value
of z given h1.
Why is that?
That's essentially
Wald's equality.
Not Wald's identity, but Wald's
equality because--
Yes, it says from Wald's
equality, since alpha is
essentially equal to the
expected value of s of j given
h equals 1, the number of
testing you have to take when
h is equal to 1, when alpha
is very, very large, is
effectively the amount of time
that it takes you to get up to
the point alpha.
That expected amount of time is
typically pretty close to
the mean value.
So alpha there is close to the
expected value of s of j given
h equals 1.
So Wald's equality, given h
equals 1, says the expected
value of j given h1 is equal
to the expected value of sj
given h equals 1, that's alpha,
divided by the expected
value of z given h1,
which is just the
underlying likelihood ratio.
So to get this result, we just
substitute alpha for the
expected value.
And then the probability of
error, given h equals 0, if we
write it this way, we see
the cost immediately.
That's the expected value
of j given h equal to 1.
In other words, the expected
number of tests given h equals
1 times the expected value of
the log likelihood ratio given
h equals 1.
When you decrease beta, that
lowers the probability of
error given h1 exponentially,
but it increases the number of
tests when h0 is the
correct hypothesis.
So in that case, you get the
probability of error given h
equals 1 is effectively equal to
the expected value e to the
expected value of j
equals j equals 0.
This is just the number of tests
you have to do when h is
equal to 0.
This is the expected value of
the log likelihood ratio when
h is equal to 0.
This is very approximate, but
this is how you would actually
choose how big you make alpha,
how big do you make beta if
you want to do a test between
these two hypotheses.
Now, this shows what you're
gaining by the sequential test
over what you're gaining by
the non-sequential test.
You don't have this in your
notes, so you might just jot
it down quickly.
The expected value of z,
conditional on h equals 0, is
this slope here, the slope of
the moment generating function
is z equals 0.
That's the slope of the
underlying random variable.
Since this point is r equal to
1, this point down here is the
expected value of z
given h equals 0.
That's the exponents that you
get when h equals 0 is, in
fact, the correct exponent.
When given the probability of
error given that h is equal to
0, namely the probability that
you choose hypothesis 1.
Same way over here.
This slope here is the expected
value of the log
likelihood ratio given
h equals 1.
This hits down here at minus
expected value of z
given h equals 1.
So you have this exponent going
one way, you have this
exponent going the other way
when the thing multiplying the
exponent is not an absolute
value but is, in fact, the
number of tests you have to
do than the other test.
Now, if we do the fix test,
what we're fixed with is a
test where you take a line
tangent to this curve, which
goes from here across
here to there.
We can see-saw it around.
When we see-saw it all the way
in the limit, we can get this
result here.
But we get this result here at
the cost of an error, which is
almost one in the other
case, so that's
not a very good deal.
This says that sequential
testing, well, it shows you
how much you gain by doing
a sequential test.
I mean, it might not be
intuitively obvious why this
is happening.
I mean, really the reason it's
happening is that the times
when you want to make the test
very long are those times when
if h is equal to 0, you
normally go down.
The next most normal thing is
you wobble around without
doing anything for a long time,
in which case you want
to keep doing additional tests
until finally it falls down,
or finally it goes up.
But by taking additional
tests, you make it very
unlikely that you're ever going
to cross that threshold.
So that's the thing
you're gaining.
You are gaining the fact that
the error is small in those
situations where the sum of
these random variables stays
close to 0 for a long time, and
then you don't make errors
in those cases.
We now have just a little
bit of time to
prove Wald's identity.
I don't want to have a lot of
time to prove it because
proofs of theorems are things
you really have to look at
yourselves.
This one, you almost don't
have to look at it.
This one is almost obvious as
soon as you understand what a
tilted probability is.
So let's suppose that x sub n is
a sequence of IID discrete
random variables.
It has a moment generating
function for some given r.
We're going to assume that these
random variables are
discrete now to make this
argument simple.
If they're not discrete, this
whole argument has to be
replaced with all sorts
of [INAUDIBLE]
integrals and all
of that stuff.
It's exactly the same idea,
but it just is messy
mathematically.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to define a tilted
random variable.
A tilted random variable is a
random variable in a different
probability space.
OK, we start out with this
probability space that we're
interested in, and then we say,
OK, suppose that we, just
to satisfy our imaginations, we
suppose the probabilities
are different.
We assume that the probabilities
for a given r is
the probability that the random
variable X is equal to
little x, namely this quantity
here, is equal to the original
probability that X is
equal to little x.
All the sample values are
the same, it's just the
probability's changed, times e
to the rx minus gamma of r.
So we're taking these
probabilities when X is large.
We're magnifying them
when x is small.
We're knocking them down.
What's the purpose of this?
It's just a normalization
factor.
e to the minus gamma of r is 1
over the moment generating
function of r, so you take
p of x, e to the rx,
divide it by g of r.
So this is a probability mass
function, as well as this.
This is the correct probability
mass function for
the model you're looking at.
This is an imaginary one, but
you can always imagine.
You can say let's suppose that
we had this model instead of
the other model.
All the sample values are the
same, but the probabilities
are different.
So we want to see what we can
find out from these different
probabilities in this different
probability model.
If you sum over x here,
this sum is equal to
1, as we just said.
So we'll view q sub xr of x as
the probability mass function
on x in a new probability
space.
We can use all the laws of
probability in this new space,
and that's exactly what
we're going to do.
And we're going to say things
about the new space, but then
we can always come back to the
old space from this formula
here because whatever we find
out in the new space will work
in the old space.
One thing we'd like to do is
to be able to find the
expected value of the random
variable x in this new
probability space, so this isn't
the expected value in
the old space.
It's a probability
in the new space.
It's the sum over x of x
times q sub xr of x.
That's what the expected
value is.
X is the same in both spaces.
That's just the probabilities
that have changed.
These are p of x times z to the
rx minus gamma of r, so
when you sum this, what you get
is 1 over g of xr, which
is that term, times the
derivative of p sub x
of x, e to the rx.
When you take this derivative,
then you get an x in front,
which is that x there.
So you get g prime of xr
over gx of r, which is
gamma prime of r.
OK, so in terms of that graph
we've drawn, when you take
these tilted probabilities, you
move that slope, that r
equals 0, and now you're looking
at a slope at whatever
r you're looking at.
And that gives you the
expected value there.
OK, if you have a joint tilted
probability mass function--
and don't think it gets
any more complicated.
It doesn't.
I mean, you've already gone
through the major complication
of this argument.
The joint tilted PMF is the
probability of x1 to xn is the
old probability of x1 to xn
times all of these tilted
factors here.
If you let a of sn be the set
of n tuples which have the
same sum, then all these terms
become r times s sub n.
So what you get is that for each
xn for which the sum is
sn, this tilted probability
becomes the old probability
times e to the r sn minus n
gamma of r, which says that
when we look at the tilted
probability of the sum, namely
we said that when we tilt these
probabilities, we can do
everything in a new space that
we could do in the old space.
We can do everything that
probability theory allows us
to do, so we can look at the
probability of s sub n in the
new space also.
The probability of sn in the
old space, namely we're
summing this quantity, overall
xn in a of sn, so we sum up
all of those as the probability
sub s sub n at sn
times this quantity,
which is fixed.
So this is the key to a lot
of large deviation theory.
Any time you're dealing with a
difficult problem, and you
want to see what's happening
way, way away from the mean,
you want to see what these
sums look like for these
exceptional cases, what we do
is we look at a new model
where we tilt the probability so
that the region of concern
becomes the main region
for that tilted model.
So for r equals 0, we're
tilting the probability
towards large values, and you
can use the law of large
numbers, essential limit
theorem, whatever you want to,
in that new space, then.
Now, we can prove
Wald's equality.
What Wald's identity is is the
statement that when you tilt
these probabilities, a stopping
rule in this tilted
world is still the stopping
time is still a random
variable, namely you still
stop with probability 1.
Somebody questioned whether you
stop with probability 1 in
the old world.
Like I said, you do because
you have this positive
variance, and the thing with two
thresholds keeps growing
and growing.
Here, you have the same thing.
I mean, the mean doesn't make
any difference at all.
I mean, you're looking at trying
to exceed one of two
different thresholds, and
eventually, you exceed one of
them no matter where
you set r.
So what this is saying is the
probability that j is equal to
n in this tilted space is equal
to the probability that
j is equal to n in the old
space times z to the r sn
minus gamma of r.
So this quantity is equal to the
expected value of e to the
r sn minus gamma of r.
Given j equals n times the
probability that j is equal to
n, you sum this over n
and, bingo, you're
back at the Wald identity.
So that's all the Wald identity
is, is just a
statement that when you tilt a
probability, and you have a
stopping rule on the original
probabilities, you then have a
stopping rule on the
new probabilities.
And Wald's identity says--
well, Wald's identity holds
whenever that tilted stopping
rule is a random variable.
OK, that's it for today.
We will do martingales
on Wednesday.